- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all
of the major problems of the world.
So today's message is create your own art.
Over to you Bruce Lee.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- [Narrator] In case you
have missed the recent news,
Jeet Kune Do, of which I am the founder,
has been elected and accepted into
the black belt hall of fame in America.
This marks the first
time a recently developed
form of martial art is
nationally accepted.
No, Jeet Kune Do is not thousands
or even hundreds of years old.
It started in around 1965
by a dedicated and intensified
man called Bruce Lee.
My martial art is something that
no serious martial artist can ignore.
- If you want to reach
your true potential,
then you need to create your own art.
At the beginning, you can model success.
You can copy what other people are doing.
You can learn from others
and you can apply it
to build whatever product
or service you have up
but at some point you have to say,
this is where I deviate.
This is where I become me.
This is where I branch off
and differentiate myself
from everybody else.
At the beginning, it's
great to model success.
When I was building up my Youtube channel,
I had a media coach through my agent,
and my agent and her taught me every week
and gave me advice on how to get better.
I would copy and paste what they gave me
and it would actually never
quite work out perfectly.
I always had to tweak it.
I always had to change
it to make it fit me.
When I'm modeling Steve
Jobs or Opera Winfrey
or whoever it is, Howard Shultz,
I can't do it exactly like they did it.
Got to take it and tweak
it and make it fit for me.
That's what you have
to do in your business.
You got to find what is the unique twist
that you bring that,
yes, you can copy others
and model others but
at the end of the day,
you're switching it up and just
a little bit, little tweak.
That is unique and special.
That's why I don't care about people
who copy my Youtube channel.
People send me emails
all the time and comments
like this person copied your video
or is doing exactly like you're doing.
The best they're ever going to
be is an Evan Carmichael junior.
So I either spend my time
worrying about those guys
or I spend my time
building something better.
Like if all you're doing
is copying somebody else,
you're only going to be
a junior version of them.
So I don't care about those people
'cause they can't catch up.
They're always playing from behind.
I want to focus on
building my future forward.
I look at Lily as an example,
who's in the Unlocking Lily
series on my channel right now.
I hired her away for a full-time job.
She wanted to be a professional speaker
and so I'm coaching and
training her on how to do it.
I'm following and documenting the journey.
Hopefully you guys are
learning along in the process.
At the start, she's taking parallel paths.
She doesn't know her message yet.
She hasn't figured it out.
She's researching, she's watching videos,
she's reading, she's
trying to formulate it.
At the same time, I want her out speaking
to get the practice,
to get the experience,
to get the knowledge, to get the reps in.
So what she's doing at the
start is teaching Your One Word.
She's running workshops,
she's doing coaching,
she's doing one-on-one,
she's doing seminars,
she's doing college, she's
doing Hangouts, Skype sessions.
She's helping people around Your One Word.
And it's great.
She does bring her own little twist to it
but at the end of the day,
this is my philosophy.
Lily will not stay doing
Your One Word forever.
Otherwise, she won't be
able to unleash her art.
So she's copying and
modeling what I've done
to propel her path forward
while at the same time
figuring her message
because at some point,
her thing is going to take over.
That's what you need to do as well.
It's okay to copy somebody.
It's okay to model somebody
who's done a lot more than you.
But at some point, you need to break off
and say here's where I'm different.
Here's where I'm special.
Here's a little magic
dust that only I can bring
to this new way of doing something.
When you do that and
you create your own art,
that's when you will
reach your true potential.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious
what is the unique thing that you bring
that's different from everybody
else in your industry?
What is your unique art?
I'm really curious.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I want to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Joel Wasserman.
Joel, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
Really, really, really
means a lot to me man
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I was drawn into a plumbing trade.
I didn't give a (swear
bleeps) about plumbing,
didn't know anything about plumbing.
I just went on that side because culture
told me that that's what I have to do.
I done it for a while and then I realized
this is not what I want to do.
If this is not what I want to do
then what the (swear
bleeps) am I doing it for?
I walked out 18 months in maybe.
- There was a concern there for us,
for his mother and father.
We didn't know what he was going to do
to be honest with you.
Early on, obviously I
didn't know what it was.
I couldn't look to my mother and say, hey.
This Irishman, Donnie, I'm
going to follow in his footsteps
because there was no footsteps.
I had to create my own
footsteps and follow them.
They were a little unsure at first
but they supported me and
they knew I would do it
if I said I'd do it, I'd do it, so.
- The question is, are we rock and roll?
(audience cheers and claps)
And I say you're goddamn
right, we rock and roll.
(audience cheers louder)
See, rock and roll is not an instrument.
Rock and roll is not
even a style of music.
Rock and roll is a spirit.
It's a spirit.
It's been going since the blues,
jazz, bebop, soul, R&B, rock and roll,
heavy metal, punk rock, and yes, hip hop.
(audience applauds)
What connects us all is that spirit.
That's what connects us all.
That spirit.
Rock and roll is not conforming
to the people who came before you,
but creating your own
path in music and in life.
That is rock and roll, and that is us.
Rock and roll is not conforming.
Rock and roll is outside the box.
Rock and roll is N.W.A.
I want to thank everybody
who helped induct us
into the rock and roll hall of fame.
I just want to tell the world
damn that was dope.
Thank you, we out of here.
- I tell all young people,
I say to you right now.
Stop looking for employment.
Why don't you position
yourself differently
and look for deployment?
To employees, to be employed means that
somebody else is benefiting
from your energy.
To deploy means, to deploy yourself
means that you are using your
own energy to be productive.
So instead of waiting for
somebody to give you a job,
create your own work.
That's why I tell, 'cause it's different
between your work and your job.
Your job is what they train you to do.
Your work is what you were born to do.
Your job is your skill
which they can fire you from at anytime.
But your work is your gift.
No one can take that from you.
Your job is for you to get
compensation for activity.
Your work is when you get fulfillment
'cause you love it so much.
Your job, you can retire from.
Your work, you can never retire
from your work 'cause your work is you.
So when a person discovers their work,
they no longer need a job
'cause their work makes them productive.
So the young people in this country
who are full of talent, full of gifts
and I want to say this too.
Every problem in life is a business.
All business is simply
someone solving a problem.
So the more problems that I encounter,
the more businesses available
for young people to begin.
This is what I think we're lacking.
We are trained to get a job.
We are trained to start a business.
We are trained to let
other people employ us
not trained to deploy ourselves.